so today's session is about the
entrepreneurship because
and of Japan and there are very few
people in the world who can at the same
time give you the background context to
really understand what's important
versus what's kind of noise and who have
really the most up-to-date knowledge of
anybody that anybody can have in regard
to what's going on in the system right
now our speaker today is Alan miner
who's the chairman of sun bridge
corporation Alan started son bridge back
in 1999 and that may be an interesting
kind of point of departure for us today
but Alan has been either in Japan or
back and forth to Japan at least since
1986-87 because he was the co-founder of
oracle japan oracle subsidiary in Japan
in 1987 served not only an executive
positions in Oracle Japan but also in
positions in the parent company here in
the International and product divisions
in 99 after starting son bridge he then
went on to join the board of directors
of salesforce.com Japan subsidiary
served on the board of salesforce.com in
Japan for 10 years he has founded a
number of companies he started son
bridge really what I would say is to
build bridges between startup companies
in Silicon Valley and startup companies
in Japan and maybe a good place to kind
of start out is to ask you what it was
like in 1999 in Japan Ireland a bit
Valley that's kind of yeah so from about
96 97 there was a wave of people who'd
been studying at Harvard Business School
or Stanford people who had come out of
top Japanese universities joined great
companies been sent to the u.s. to study
and in the middle of the internet bubble
when they came home decided what they
wanted to do is start an Internet
company
because they'd experienced the u.s.
tornado so people like me - I'm from
Rock 1040 son of Globus Ishiguro son at
net age and other so there was there was
this wave of top Japanese talent who
were being groomed for executive roles
in traditional economy who got the
internet bug and at the same time there
were a lot of students in undergraduate
programs in Japan at the time who
observed that their colleagues were
struggling figure out what they wanted
to do with their lives after college and
particularly towards the end of the
first Lost Decade of Japan late 90s I'm
forgetting the name of the securities
company that went bankrupt and now spend
so long that it's not forgotten but
there were there was there were layoffs
happening the big companies for the
first time and there was of course news
of all the exciting things happening in
the internet in the States and so you
had a wave of people like who Jesus on
it cyber agent it's probably the most
famous and successful one of the college
kids starting startups and and then
organizations like epic that were formed
to place students in internship roles in
small startups to expose them to
alternative careers than joining a big
company so there was a lot of and well
the bit valley movement really started
largely around the students looking at
doing internet things and the gentleman
named Ishikawa son who had worked for
AOL Japan and tried to bring Amazon in
Japan so 30-something
you know early internet local
entrepreneur who got a group together to
talk about how they could make Shibuya
the center of high-tech startups in
Japan and it kind of that that movement
kept gaining more momentum and there
were more and more college kids starting
companies joining startups through about
2001 I think in February of 2000 there
was a huge event at the biggest disco in
Tokyo and so and some flew in an
airplane to give a speech and a lot of
cheering and and that was kind of last
big hurrah of the bid valley movement as
a movement and from then on that was one
that was there for the yeah
I'm not report.com crash a lot of lot of
enthusiastic people but kind of Oz that
was all going on in classic Japanese
Mitty driven
industrial planning a couple of key
people within MIT II had been coming to
Silicon Valley from about 1996 1997 to
study the legal framework and the
ecosystem framework for how startups got
started and funded in Japan and I
remember being interviewed by the Cacho
in charge of that a couple of times here
in Silicon Valley and once or twice back
in Japan as they were developing the
legal framework and the government
policy agenda to get an active
innovation ecosystem so there was all
this the social like youth movement
going on in Shibuya but the same time
MIDI was was taking very serious and
proactive approach to looking at what
needed to be done in Japan to facilitate
an active startup ecosystem so it out of
that in about 2002 or so you've had a
major revision of the Commercial Code
they moan boo I don't remember if MIDI
pushed them or from Abukar gaku so in
competition with MIDI about the same
time a better year later than that I
think introduced a program to encourage
all the universities in Japan to launch
technology licensing offices and to set
a goal to have a thousand university
affiliated startups
launched in Japan before the end of the
decade so there was a lot of movement on
the part of the government kind of
coming out of this but I think put in
place a more stable permanent
underpinning for dynamics are turkey
rasathi Co system but yet Japan's had
this long reputation of being kind of
unfriendly towards startup cherries and
sure not entrepreneurial in this whole
kind of culture do you think that saw
deserved one of the main reasons yeah i
i i i think one thing one mistake we
make in Silicon Valley is comparing
every other community every other
startup community or country to Silicon
Valley and I think Silicon Valley is
highly highly unique on the extreme end
of the startup ecosystems
Japan may be highly unique and different
on the opposite end of the spectrum so I
thought I don't think Japan's reputation
for a lack of entrepreneurship a lack of
interesting assign startups is
undeserved but in every generation you
know whether the the regardless of how
supportive or effective the ecosystem is
or is not you've had in each generation
some exceptional entrepreneurs emerge
even out of that relatively you know
unsupportive own from the apartment so
you have people like yun ice on it fast
retailing Uniqlo brands and songsong
from the 1980s and a number of others in
the nineteen eyes you have the teletype
people I mentioned who left MBA programs
the United States to start companies in
Japan then in the 2000 you have a
handful of people who like nambus on
from McKinsey who started DNA and
Monica's founder okey son who was at
Goldman Sachs and left to start the
Japan's first online discount broker so
you have you have in each generation
despite despite issues with the
ecosystem you have some exceptional
entrepreneurs emerging but I think as a
society as a country a lot of Jeff
Japan's entrepreneurial ambition
creative talent continues to be pretty
well leveraged by the large corporations
and smart talented ambitious people are
drawn to go and and apply their talents
in the place where they think they can
have the most impact on society in the
easiest most impactful way I think to a
larger degree than the United States
starting to a larger degree than Silicon
Valley so that tends to ward actually
hired yeah they're actually hot they're
actually hired and developed and and and
I think one of the one of the unique and
interesting is about large Japanese
companies is they still take a very what
we would call a conglomerate approach I
think they're very open minded to
launching new lines of business that are
out not just the trading companies but
even industrial companies will launch
find a business that are out of what
anyone would think of is their core
competency because there's someone
inside who wants to do it
and has the talent and the ambition and
the company has the funding to support
it so you see a lot more out of the core
competency innovation I think happening
in big Japanese companies than you would
in in a big company United States and so
some of the entrepreneur talent I think
gets it gets developed and and leveraged
there for the interesting kind of
insight because I think a lot of the
things what happens here somebody has an
idea inside a big company and that's not
our business is our business yeah and so
I think I think the propensity in Japan
if there's someone who's talented
ambitious who has built these
relationships big Japanese companies I
think are more it's you know it's not
the it's not the typical pattern but
they are much more open-minded I think
about keeping the people in the in the
family and if if the business looks like
it might be interesting and make money
over long term Dell Dell invest and
enable people to and so that's why you
have come to like taupe on it started in
printing doing RFID tag software
solution is specifically that kind of
evolution or my favorite example of this
I don't know if I would say it was smart
but I remember an article from The Wall
Street Journal in the late 1980s when
Nippon Steel was struggling and going
through restructuring they launched the
space space music park in Kyushu but in
the same article announcing this big
space themed amusement park one of the
managers in Nippon Steel was going to
launch a chain of flower shops and how
you go from especially steel
manufacturing to a chain of flower shops
heaven heaven couldn't guess but the the
value of the relationship between of the
people in the institution and leveraging
their creativity giving them some some
room to explore and experiment and try
new things for me that the the Nippon
Steel flower shop chain it's why we the
most extreme example I can never
remember hearing about of how the value
of the interpersonal relationships and
leveraging there
are able to nurture new business lines
basically keeping the same either
overall company structure at least the
same business root structure now so what
if I think that basically how come this
doesn't allow for great world leading
companies kind of which I think is the
distinctive feature yeah we could come
from here I think it might it might be
because probably the strongest town the
best talent and the strongest talent in
the big companies continue to fight to
prevent to become the CEO of the company
so the the the absolute best of the best
in the big companies stay with the core
business and pursue a career leading the
core business and probably the only
example where you get a much more
variety in the business of the really
town of people is in the trading company
so I look at the trading companies as
historically the alternative to venture
capital in Japan because they invest in
a broad variety of businesses they
recruit and retain some of the best
talent they they have you know financial
arms that have a lot of capital to
invest they're not afraid to investment
so I thought as I was thinking about you
know why is the how is he because of
some different there than here because
there plenty of creative people plenty
of ambitious Entre Nous real people in
Japan how do they how do they express
their desires and achieve their goals
and I realized at one point that that
probably the closest thing to a hands-on
Silicon Valley venture capitalist really
engaged with the founders really
supportive over the long haul is is the
trading companies planning division yes
to make sure many people know what we're
talking about when we talk about trading
companies companies like me to be she's
Sumitomo Mitsui that have you know
multiple for some of them hundreds of
years of history with a financial
business at the core and a collection of
sometimes hundreds of affiliate
subsidiary companies in just as many
businesses there are companies yeah and
their whole reason for existence is to
make new business yeah
that's a very they're whole deals their
whole their holds are the basic business
culture and the basic philosophy is find
new ways to do some good in the world
and make some money while doing it yeah
and so that that that that ecosystem of
so go show show the trading company I
think also captures a significant amount
of the entrepreneurial talent in Japan
but the more directly relevant answered
that question is Silicon Valley setting
is what about the independent startup
scene the entrepreneurs that start
coming so what what are the differences
there and I think probably the biggest
difference that makes it harder for an
independent startup entrepreneur to have
the kind of impact in Japan coming out
of Japan is as you see coming out of
Silicon Valley or recently quite a bit
out of China is the relative sparsity of
funding so now that impacts there's a
little number ways so just just a little
bit of data to help frame that gap in
the United States typically about 50 to
80 billion depending the year 58 yeah
tens of billions of dollars a year are
invested in venture capital each year in
China last year fifty billion dollars
was invested in China based startups a
lot of it domestics are coming overseas
if you look at a list of the top funded
the the most significant hundred
companies and this is a little fun doing
a little bit research for today's talk
on this the the the biggest funded
company in the world everyone probably
knows is uber what you may not know is
that of the top ten eight of them are
Chinese based companies
so after ubers 14 oh nope I'm sorry I am
possibly wrong I've got this down as
DeeDee and China
Uber's company has actually has actually
raised 18 billion versus ubers 14 Wow
and then in China you have company
mobile can't finance something you have
a number you have four more companies
have been funded have raised a total of
four billion dollars and then you go to
Singapore where there's a company lazada
that raised four billion dollars and the
uber competitor there raised 3.5 you
come back finds the United States at
about rank 11 with in for out of New
York and one web out of Virginia Airbnb
somewhere in that range
of the ten most highly funded companies
that are still startups nine of them
from China and the other one is do worry
so but when you get down to that level
of 2.6 billion which is the 11
11th company level that is the total
funding of all startups in Japan last
year which was a record breaking year
yes total of all 11 capital yeah they
told the total of all venture capital
invested in Japan last year was what was
spent on infor
out of New York or daiquan which is a
basically online auto loan service in
China so one one company in China one
company New York raised as much money
over its over its relatively short
lifetime than all the money invested in
Japan last year so it gives you sort of
a sense of the gap that said that 2.6
billion dollars is two and a half times
what Japan has traditionally trended at
Japan's total venture capital onions
have been about a billion dollars a year
for a long time and it's moved up a
little bit as the economy improves if
the stock market improves and and the
funding for venture capital all over the
world tends to trend pretty closely with
how the public equity markets are doing
in those countries but the 2.6 billion
dollars invested in Japan last year is a
record I haven't seen it in the 19 I've
seen it reach 2 billion dollars once
before but this is the first time I've
seen it go significantly about two
billion dollars in Japan in 20 years so
is this a blue piece of change I think
it's a gradual trend i I think if you
look at if you look at a number of other
data for example you look at the number
of companies that individual companies
who raised ten million dollars in a
single funding round in Japan that that
number has been trending up steadily
slowly but steadily every year since
2012 about 50 companies or so last year
that each raised more than 10 million
dollars in financing in Japan and it
grew from about a little about one and a
quarter percent of all investments in
Japan to about eight percent so about
about 8 percent of the startup funding
in Japan now are at the level of 10
million dollars where 20 years ago in
Silicon Valley a 10 million dollar
funding round was a nice size what you
can do
huh you can do an awful lot of
$10,000,000 especially if all of your
competitors are only being funded about
that level now the the there are a
couple of other things so we've talked a
little bit company innovation I think
one of the ways Japan you know before
you go to with us yeah yeah so
okay the trends toward venture capital
investment is kind of steady for a long
time and been sort of a shy upswing I'm
not sure that's so sharp but it's it
feels it feels a little more craft so it
was a billion a billion and a half two
billion two billion about half okay so
there seems to be a steady increase and
certainly on the the larger the larger
financing rounds that's been increasing
yeah within the last few years we've
seen the first two or three companies
raised a total of so the the top eleven
companies funding historically 2.6
billion the the company that has raised
more money privately than any other in
Japan is one of my favorites they're
called spy BER
they've raised a total of 126 million
dollars over the ten years or so you've
been in existence and that's that's been
enough to do and I maybe we'll talk
about a little bit later but they've
accomplished an enormous amazing amount
I'm heartened to exceed six million
dollars but that's that's the moat the
most funded private company in Japan is
you know at that level that's its level
of the most funded company in Nebraska
the biggest funded company in New Jersey
the biggest funded company in Idaho is
about the size about has raised about as
much funding as the biggest funded
company in Japan okay so along with
increasing in investments are you seeing
anything else in just the last year -
and in Japan or what kind of recent
things do you see now
well I'm there you'd asked you're in our
in our profession about talent and I my
gut has been telling me that I'm seeing
better than better talent joining
startups in Japan but then as I as I sat
down and kind of tried to make a list
I'm not sure that's true
because I kind of went back and well you
know you've had people like so and so
you have people like me to tell us and
you've had people economic number sites
you've had your full of exceptional
startup leaders in Japan nice and I
think as I look at the startups I'm
watching or involved with I'm still
seeing as compared to startups here or
what I assume is happening with these
incredibly over funded startups in China
is you have a very powerful bench a very
powerful leadership match you'd have
talent of the same caliber as a numbaz
on in six key positions in DNA for
example if that were the ice or or
someone like Koki when starting monix
instead of hiring students fresh out of
college or as nambus on hired first year
employees at Oracle Japan stole some
bright young people that Oracle trained
for a year very young in experienced
people to build out her management bench
the Japanese company still tend to be
very much dominated by the single
founder as a group you know there are
exceptions there are sometimes you do
good job of hiring a management team but
the management team always tends to be
junior in terms of age experience to the
founder and the it's very rare to have
co-founders where ownership of the
company is split equally between
co-founders so the Japanese startups
tend to be very much dominated by both
in ownership and in leadership by a
single founder and in depend much more
so than in starts United States on the
talent and ability to continue to lead
and grow as a leader of the founder over
the life and I think that that's that's
some wag that's a difference I'd noticed
over the years partly because of what
you say I think is that the founder has
such a kind of possessive sense company
that the exit patterns in Japan
really different than them um yeah do
you have kind of what's your take on
that side of the system well I think
actually one of one of the I'm not sure
if it's I'm not sure anymore if I think
of it as an advantage or a disadvantage
of the this image of man but but a huge
difference it is it is still possible to
take a small company public in Japan and
when I'm saying small there are a number
of companies that went public last year
on a revenue base of five million
dollars now they weren't Internet age
startup so we had five million dollars
in revenues and fifty million dollars in
losses like was happening in America in
1999 these are five million dollar
companies making a little bit of profit
and growing at maybe twenty or thirty
percent and and it is amazing to me that
that the big underwriters like Nomura
and Daiwa Securities and musical
securities will actually engage these
companies and go through the effort
required to help them list as publicly
traded companies but of course on that
kind of revenue base if I feel was a
one-time event the amount of capital
that you could raise for coming at size
is trivial and so it provides it
provides a way to become public to
provide liquidity for the shareholders
provide liquidity for the founder some
some founders see being public as a
badge of honor and so there's there's
certainly a little bit of
entrepreneurial pride associated with
being pup who stood in Japan and many
many many companies list at 15 or 20
million in sales and the only companies
that get to a hundred million or more in
sales before going public in Japan are
usually spin-offs of large already
established spin-offs of large companies
so it's very unusual for a company to
stay private and grow to the size and
scale with private financing or to grow
based on financing while still having a
negative PNL to use venture capital or
private equity in its larger more
extensive form to continue growing this
the size of the organization and growing
the impact in the economy growing the
size of the revenues on a money-losing
basis
from a pl point of view before as long
as it can be done the United States
China so I think the ability to the lack
of funding leads to issues around what
salaries are paid to employees that the
level of talent you hire how you evolve
the management team over time and how
large the company ultimately grows so
there's kind of a mystery kind in this
in this you know small company going
public because certainly the people here
who would prevent that from happening or
the venture capital investment right
right and in Japan it's usually the
venture capital investors that push
should happen they have they have
end-of-life injure cabs everywhere have
end-of-life issues with their funds and
if a company is not ready to exit before
the font the most influential investors
are hitting their ten-year or extended
12-year deadlines on the life of their
funds in the US they'll push those
they'll start working those companies to
push them to be acquired by someone to
do a trade sale so you can exit or buy
where in Japan there's not there's not
as active trade sale scene and so to do
one of two things happens the early
investors will ask for the founder to
buy back their shares or to or to assist
in a in a one-off private placement to
find a buyer for so the CEOs get asked
to act as investment bankers on behalf
of the early VCS by finding a corporate
or some other investor who will actually
take the shares off their hands
hopefully at a profit sometimes at a
loss or or if if the characters of the
business such that the leading VCS think
that it that the securities firms could
execute a successful IPO for it they
will they will push small companies to
go public as a way to provide an exit
for the investor so so that's the cause
the investors and the VC companies are
expecting early return but maybe not the
big returns that we're looking for
you know the quote homeruns yeah so so
the whole the whole the whole ecosystem
is such that investors and there's
there's there are more entrepreneurs
than there are in there's capital there
are more ideas more businesses being
formed
is capital to support them and so as a
rule for the bulk of the startup
companies in Japan investors can invest
at a pretty reasonable valuation and so
if part of part of what's going on in
Silicon guy China is that the
investments are so large and coming at
such high valuations that there's a lot
of pressure you have to grow the
business to match the size that I wish
to be message put in and in Japan
because the the businesses tend to be
run more in the mentality of a small
businessman as opposed to what we would
think of as a start-up entrepreneur
they're run more like small businesses
if they're growing if they're reaching a
certain level of profitability and
there's reasonable prospects for growth
and the investments were made on
reasonable terms a small IPO with a you
know valuation of twenty or thirty or
forty million dollars after the IPO is
enough to make a reasonable return not a
homerun return but a positive return
other young investors and so there's the
whole the whole expectation around the
jet the the average expectation the
average expectation around the returns
to the founding team returns to the
investors on a start-up pitch pan look
more like you would think of as a small
business hopper investing in small
businesses in the States maybe how do
the big companies that are making
strategic corporate venture capital
investments fit into this picture what I
what I'm seeing they're there to kind of
classes of corporate venture capital
firms in Japan one is actually startups
that have done public and there's a
there's an interesting phenomenon in
Japan because you can't you can't the
underwriters and the public markets are
not comfortable valuing companies based
on revenue growth if they're losing
money so there's a there's a requirement
that is rarely is almost it's 99% of the
time whatever the size of the company
they will be turning a profit
it'll be expected to continue growing
that profit
but so if you if you're say 20 million
and says you've got a million in profits
you raise five or ten million in your
IPO Sayuri's ten million in the IPO menu
you're producing a million profits and
there are things you could do with your
business to invest for more growth you
could maybe launch an International
office or develop a second product line
there are things there are a lot of
things you could do with ten million
dollars if you're a small company still
growing
to grow your own business but the minute
you spend if you've decided to spend
that ten million dollars on a two-year
project to expand internationally or to
your product to building a product line
suddenly you've gone from producing a
million in profit to formerly in their
losses the next two years and that's
that's the kind of behavior that venture
capital investors want to see they want
to see their money invested for growth
and it's the kind of behavior that
public investors are comfortable with
because they see they see a company was
it was making them in doesn't suddenly
it's losing a lot of money why so what
happened what happened I won't sell my
stock tomorrow instead of whatever yeah
there's a little quick that's right
that's right you know if you're if
you're these are trading horizon for
investors tends to be shorter as well
yeah but what what happened a lot in the
2000s and and even even recently still
happens is that what what they do with
that money is instead of just sitting in
putting in the bank to earn no interest
or nowadays to pay interest to the bank
to leave it sitting in the bank in Japan
they'll they will often use that money
to start a small fund of their own and
invest in other startups is hopefully
somehow related to their business maybe
not because they can do that as a
balance sheet transaction they don't
have to take any loss on those
investments for a few years at least and
if a couple of them pay off they make a
they make an investment return and if
they don't pay off at least they've done
something with the capital they thought
might be beneficial so there there's a
strange phenomenon of newly listed
startups investing in other startups in
Japan so that that's sort of a category
of it and actually I think often they
make pretty savvy investments they often
make one or two pretty savvy investments
because they're fresh out of a category
and and people see them as
mentors and and are more willing to
listen to their advice so there's
there's a good hands I met your capital
dynamic dynamic that happens a lot of
times between the founder of a recently
public startup and the the smaller
startups that they invest in there's a
whole other category of becoming like
Panasonic that have been doing cbc in
japan for ages and KDDI and DoCoMo
who've both had funds now for quite a
while and then TT group has a several
community would have funds and Hitachi's
and others and a good percentage of the
CBC fund sitting in the large
corporations are looking for technology
plays in Silicon Valley there's there
they're looking to find out what's going
on in Silicon Valley what's what's the
new trend can we engage in a business
relationship with a cool new startup in
Silicon Valley by admission so there's a
there's a lot a lot of overseas
investment the the exception I think has
been the KDDI in NTT DoCoMo funds who
have invested more like Intel Capital
does around the world in interesting
mobile startups in Japan they think can
move the needle on there are poo on the
skyways offer interesting services to
their mobile phone subscriber base that
their competitors don't have so there's
a that the the mobile phone the CBC's in
Japan tend to be much more interested in
locking in relationships with
interesting local or at least Asian
regional
mobile phone so just being company's
play kind of a very difficult position
if you think about it they siphon off
good talent even if they're not getting
all the good talent yeah
and I are providing some funding into
the venture capital scene yeah
what about b2b type situations do they
buy from startup companies well yeah so
that that's that's a common question I
get is you know and and a lot of
Japanese charters will say well it
should be great to be doing business in
Japan because American companies will
buy from startups and Japanese Consulate
buy from startups American companies
will buy from startups Japanese company
don't buy from startups they they buy
from a team that they learned to trust
through an effective usually long sales
engagement a product that they think is
unique enough to be worth taking the
risk on buying it from a start-up and so
the dynamic that I now my in my
observation I don't see a huge
difference in the dynamic and the issues
and the challenges of selling to an
established company in selling a new
selling a new startups product to an
established company in Japan versus
United States it's the same you have the
same set of issues and challenges and
and I know plenty of Japanese companies
that play of startups in Japan who have
successfully sold to Japanese large
corporations from very early in their
history and my what my fav my favorite
two anecdote of this is there's a
there's a startup we invested in years
ago called okay wave it's kind of cure
five years before cure was launched this
may be the easiest way to to understand
it but their their business model was or
what they've developed besides a public
question-answer site they developed a
business model around helping companies
develop their corporate fa Q's for their
call center customer support desk so
they had this summer product and the
founder is just this extremely high
energy and Souza guy he always shakes
we've had with both hands and you you
can't help getting all warm and loving
him three minutes after meeting him and
he'd been trying and trying to get
companies big companies to buy his
cute product and he was in the meeting
with some junior staff person at Sony
one day and and was told what we don't
buy software from startups and he had
the brilliant insight and like said you
know it always comes down to sales and
building a relationship been having a
product that's worthwhile and says well
wasn't Sonia start up what once how did
you guys ever get off the ground if you
don't mind if nobody buys from startups
how did Sony get started and it was just
it was just the right thing to say to
the person any kind of so yeah I guess I
guess let's take a look and and over
over an engagement of a few weeks or
months of proving the product could do
what they wanted and what they said and
that you know that moment of insight
aniss in a sales situation to kind of
remind them of their roots was enough to
add many many many of the startups that
we've worked with in Japan have lots of
big corporate customers but it takes
time and and if the first the first big
company to buy a product from a start-up
I like bow down and and honor them
whether they're in the United States or
Japan because that the the person in a
big company will take the risk on a
start-up because they like the CEO or
the salesperson or or they think they
think this might do enough to move the
needle for their company that they're
willing to take that take make that bet
that that that individual in in the big
company that's willing to make that bet
whether it's in Japan or Silicon
Valley's its kind of Johnson with a mind
of about yes sure called sure so I was
asked by NEC corporation to run a panel
discussion of public about the future of
the microprocessor and and first of all
they managed to get president John
Hennessy to cloud and be one of the
panelists in this presentation and
because that was his work and he had
founded MIPS and NEC was like his first
customer yeah yeah so you know I am told
by the president's office
he's only got ten minutes you know make
sure you let him talk first and then
leave and so I set it up I gave him ten
minutes and kind of said thanks very
much he stayed there
for an hour and a half Wow I'm watching
the people in the back of the room on
their telephones and rearranging of
schedules
yeah all because they were his first big
customer yeah yeah so I know it's hard
for strep everywhere yeah I can I hear I
hear from starts in America hardest to
get a bit company to buying here from
Japanese what I don't hear I don't hear
Americans start saying it would be so
easy to sell this product to a Japanese
big company I wish I was starting up in
Japan but I hear I hear that grass is
greener on the other side of the ocean
comment from Japanese on tears a lot
more than I then I hear it here but it's
so why why does Japan have this terrible
reputation I think to a certain extent
Japanese people believe this terrible
reputation yeah if you look at the
surveys that are done very few people in
Japan say that they see opportunities
for entrepreneurs there's a low
percentage of the population involved in
entrepreneurial activity yeah is it all
just kind of mass depression oh I think
part of it part of it lies in Japan
strength in innovation in large
corporations so the world knows Toyota
and Sony and Panasonic and and there's a
Nintendo and there's a long history of
awareness of how successful and
innovative and globally influential the
big Japanese companies are so we we I
think we come to the question of if you
were a somebody named a great company
out of Japan only people in private
equity might think of saying Softbank
top ahead anybody else's in say Toyota
or Panasonic or Sony or Nintendo or
Studio Ghibli and very people who
top-of-mind would say Rakuten nobody
outside Japan would say monix mama do in
Japan would say monix so if you think of
like innovative leading Japanese
companies there are very innovative
entrepreneurial companies but our brand
association with Japan is around the the
the the global fortune 100 global
innovative brats you you asked a little
bit in one of the pre-accession
questions about hiring and employees and
it prompted me to see if I could find
some data on what young people are
thinking today and there's a survey that
a student group did of several hundred
Japanese students asking whether they
wanted to work for a start-up or large
corporation upon graduation and to be
honest I was surprised at how many said
startup really yeah so three percent of
the students that were on this survey
said strongly strong preference toward
for a startup
not surprisingly I'd have to actually
publish and pull videos just some and
eight percent said you know if you know
one all things being equal a start-up
more than big company so startup only 3%
another 7% probably a startup rather
than a big company and absolutely a big
company with something like 30 percent
maybe you didn't know was twenty seven
percent twenty four percent absolutely
big company 24 percent big company
rather than a start-up and about 27% no
real opinion anybody that will hire me
I'll work was sort of the the the not
surprisingly uncommitted Japanese sort
of answer where ever I can get a job off
of but but so I was I was surprised that
ten percent of students graduating from
college expressed a preference to work
in a start-up and I would be surprised
if outside Silicon Valley in the United
States the preference for a start-up as
opposed to a big established company was
much greater among American students
than among Japanese students I think you
know globally there's some wonderful
global brands and it's a fairly unusual
individual who has such a clear view of
what they want to do with their life and
how what kind of experiences they want
to get when they're young that they
choose a start-up as the way that that
they want to learn and grow and express
themselves as opposed to an
establishment fan so I would be
surprised if the data was that
dramatically different for American
students then
Japanese students so that was kind of
surprising yeah so thanks to Alan's
invitation we both cooperate in putting
on the japan-us Innovation Awards each
year and last month we just gave out the
2018 awards for outstanding innovation
yep and we had two US companies that
received the award we work in Foghorn
systems and three Japanese companies
that receive the award cloudian and mu
jean which does kind of like the
controller box for robot and Sorek um
which is basically your own SIM card for
an IOT system one of the things you said
at that time was that really you could
stand these startups against a
successful startup anywhere and its
really been kind of unusual you haven't
seen Japanese startups that you don't
have to sort of make balances for yeah
yeah so we've we've been doing this
program for it what about years and
years though and I remember in the in
the very early bored means we was kind
of designing the program we wanted to
have an award for emerging new leaders
an award for more established leading
already changing the world yeah we even
tried to tease out something about
innovation happening in big companies
and we never proved never we never find
a big company in the United States that
we could knew that that much detail
about to the US but but what we struggle
with first couple years is we were to
say well let's find companies in a bid
form for let maybe less than five or ten
years to do the emerging leader one and
maybe some companies that are just comp
up we're about to go public for the this
morning when we kept finding that the
company the later stage companies in
Japan were not unreasonable peers to
brand new companies in Silicon Valley
and and we struggled to find equally
young companies that were equally
impressive in both markets or when they
were a later stage also you know is
still the gap at a later stage was also
quite significant so we sort of ended up
blending it into one word and we we
tolerated that we'd have more mature
companies from Japan on stage with
younger companies for the United States
and if you if you play the game that way
on stage the Japanese companies and
American companies look look similarly
innovative similarly impressive and and
so we kind of designed the program so
close sharing the dirty laundry here
about how we had to make this program
work this year was the first time in
eight years where I think all three of
the Japanese companies on you know
head-to-head competition there's similar
ages uh all three of those are both
technologically and in terms of the
potential impact of the business in the
larger economy more interesting than the
the company is often listed from Silicon
Valley's here and I and I know I didn't
expect to see that I and so it was it
was quite impressive to me to see three
companies who gave great presentations
in the English language who knew how to
talk about their business in a simple
and compelling way and where the
underlying business was clearly
game-changing for their customers so so
that was sort of a setting early into
coming speakers like well if if Japan
has gotten to the point where you know
the companies emerging in Japan are as
good as some of the best in emerging at
Silicon Valley
maybe we're in a new era in Japan and
sadly I think I I think where we are is
there are now entrepreneurs and there is
an ecosystem of finance ears around them
that can now create Silicon Valley
quality companies I think if you were to
do if it were took at quantity we could
probably we could probably not find more
than one or two more in Japan of that
same caliber today we could probably
find 30 or 40 or 50 more in certain
value of that same ever same colors so I
think I think on a on a on a narrow on a
narrow selection of companies the the
quality a similar quality of Emmys are
emerging you look on handful and I but I
think but I think there's there's a
larger quantity of similarly high cloud
my guess my guess there's a large
quantity of similarly high quality
companies being formed in Silicon Valley
well that would make sense we want
invest in Twitty
five billion dollars in venture capital
a steer and so ten times as much as in
Japan at least yeah so what one of one
of my my fun somewhat somewhat cynical
but somewhat serious remarks on how
startup ecosystems work is you only get
companies like Google or uber or
saddle-sore scam or Facebook in a
startup environment where you're willing
to waste 90 to 95% of all the money
invested so if you if you we and I'm
sure there's a lot of lot of wasted
capital going into startups in China
there's a lot of wasted capital going
into startups in Japan and California
there's there's a little bit wasted in
Japan as well I was unfortunately on the
board of a company that raised 40
million dollars and kind of fell apart
there's lots of management conflicts and
anyway so not ever not every deal in
Japan works out either but to get to get
the really extraordinary world-changing
X incredibly a quick growth two billion
dollars in revenue the phenomenon that
you see in Silicon Valley and China now
you have to waste billions of dollars in
deals that are going to pan out or in
copycat companies that are gonna you
know not not not every company going
after a space is gonna win there's gonna
be one one winner and one or two you
know viable followers and the other 10
or 20 companies that we're all trying to
do the same thing we're gonna fail and
so there's so part of part of part of
the Silicon Valley ecosystems success is
driven by a willingness by the VCS and
an astonishing willingness by the LPS
that back those funds to waste an awful
lot of money on the chance that you may
you may hit on one grand slam home run
yeah one time we had a one of the
partners from YC speak and at that point
Y Combinator had had six hundred and
seventy something companies go through
the Algrim yeah
two-thirds of their total capital gain
overall the history of Y so yeah came
from three company yeah not surprising
out of the six hundred and
yes but Alan what about other companies
in Japan that you think are interesting
that we ought to take a look at it well
there were the three this year the three
the three Messiaen Japan this year I
thought mu Jean was quite amazing
it's basically software to have an AI
learning based algorithm for how robot
picking arms move and so the movement
looks more like a smooth human more
moving there's a little bit of
randomness to it but it's sort of a
goal-oriented discover how the arms
should move to accomplish a task and
they have they've actually implemented a
100% no humans touch anything
distribution center for the biggest EC
logistics company in China called JD
logistics where various electronic goods
come in and shipments they get unboxed
they get stopped orders come in they get
pulled stuck stuck in bubble wrap loaded
up in boxes that are cut to size based
on the contents of the box and so
basically from the time a truck arrives
at the loading dock until the boxes go
out in another truck to be delivered
there is not a human involved in any
step of the process from accepting em
and it's because of largely because of
their AI based robot control innovations
they're suffered so that was to me a
really amazing time I'm did pre
disclosing my vote for them for the
winter in Japan this year but but there
there will be other opinions I'm sure
but for me for me the the company that
is my favorite startup in Japan the one
though the one that I'm watching and
cheering and hoping it changes the world
the way that it could there's a company
called spy BER that I met about eight
years ago when there were four kids in
the keio university biotech grad school
who had stumbled on me let me show it
out this is not happening in Tokyo this
is happening in the thriving city of
Ephesus in a wave little tiny town
upon the Northwest select an hour north
of Niigata on the west coast of Japan
nothing in the town but my wife's
uncle's optometry clinic and pseudo and
Spiker
but in keio university so are these
other four biotech so I'm not I'm not
sure how much of their story I can tell
publicly versus what I can't but I what
I know I can't help obviously the
original idea was to create
bioengineered bacteria that could
produce long strands of spider silk and
spider silk you may not know is one of
the most durable flexible lightweight
natural materials that exists and DARPA
has had projects they funded at DuPont
to get goats to produce spider silk in
goat milk and extract it from that so
there's a next generation after carbon
fiber technology there's been quite a
bit of efforts to try and figure out how
to mass produce spider silk artificially
for a long time and there are a few
there are a few researchers in college
around the world that are looking at
analyzing the characteristics a spider
protein and had had a bio engineered
bacteria to produce spider silk in tiny
quantities in order to do spectral
analysis and genetic analysis and
characteristic analysis of different
breeds of spiders so the the idea that
they hit on is what if we could figure
out a way but in those in those
processes they have to kill the bat they
produce a little bit of silk inside
destroy the bacteria to extract the silk
DNA this so fibers from inside the
bacteria in their analysis there that
was what if we could figure out a way to
have and I've never been able to think
of a more polite way to say it then what
if we could figure how to get the
bacteria to poop bat poop spider silk
and to basically consume nutrients and
just keep producing without dying a long
strand of spider so then we could then
we could spin it and use bacteria to
mass-produce long strand special so that
was the research broadly embarked on as
grad students when I met them and it
the four of them I said you guys you
need to move to Silicon Valley through
this startup you need you need Silicon
Valley style funding and and more
importantly you will want the
researchers at Wyoming University and
the researchers in Germany who are doing
research on spider silk characteristics
to join your team and you'll want great
talent and people will people will if if
it's an entire it's exciting as you're
working on and it's funded by a famous
jet the Silicon Valley venture
capitalists you will be able to recruit
and retain the best talent in the world
to work on an idea that's as big as this
the idea is essentially replacing all
kinds replacing all kinds of metals
plastics I think I think that I am
allowed to say that it can't produce any
protein you know not not surprising it's
not just part of any any protein can be
artificially gene sequenced and produced
by these bacteria now so any any
material that's protein based and other
living thing base which I'm not sure how
suppose if I can get a they could that
converts off a lot of materials with
genetically modified bacteria and they
they have built a library of all kinds
of gene sequenced and ready to do a
bacteria to produce a variety of
materials
well they said now we want to Jeff go
we're gonna raise some money from Jeff
don't take any weight from Jeff go
because they will not let you move to
Silicon Valley and they'll push you to
go public way your than you then you
want to and we're gonna raise a couple
million dollars in grant money from the
Japanese government research labs that
sponsored grant we do research grants oh
that's that's good you know it'll delay
you getting serious about your business
but it's free money so go ahead to grant
and yeah like who was not able to
persuade them to come to Silicon Valley
and about two years ago they were
nominated by Forbes Japan to be I think
that you're the second most interesting
startup in Japan and I was when I was at
the awards ceremony I saw them sitting
there and I grabbed a seat in the
honorees section just I could sit next
to Seki almost on the president and chat
with him I could get caught up and he
says yeah we just we've hired three
people from overseas now I said you guys
you're still in pseudo oka yeah he said
that they had had an article in Wired on
what they were doing and an Italian
researcher had reached out to us I want
to work for your company and an Indian
researcher had reached out that I want
to become
and so they have in silk they don't have
I think 20 employees that are foreign
nationals don't speak a word of Japanese
about a hundred about a hundred fifty
yeah
who are foreign nationals of beginning
Japanese and they have gotten a local
city government to create a nursery
school for the children of these foreign
families anyway so the fact that they
they were able to raise a hundred and
thirty million dollars in capital in
Japan almost no VC it's almost all
corporate money from their their
potential customers for the product I
don't I don't know if I can name the
company but there there is a major
manufacturer in Japan with whom they're
gonna they're about to break ground on a
they finished the single production line
scale testing well I think they're about
to dunk that I can talk about how London
has brought up to here all right because
we feature them in the alam a couple of
years ago and what they brought was a
jacket from north yeah yeah their
material had been integrated a flexible
and delivered a much warmer much lighter
Aria jacket okay who's the president
brought his people over here to look at
big nursery yeah house I was not gonna
leave sudo oka yeah he was going to set
up an international nursery school and
Saturn after being yeah yeah that's cool
so so for me this this company it
they're they're basically the basic
vision of the company has to replace all
plastics and
carbon fiber based materials with a less
expensive more durable and less brittle
so if the problem with carbon fiber is
brittle they're they're spider they're
spider thread based materials are
bendable and flexible so they have they
have characteristics like metal and in
rock artists like metal lighter and so
they they are just about to break ground
on a full-scale production facility for
their main sponsor and what they've
accomplished with a hundred and twenty
million in capital which in Japan size
the biggest is the most funded startup
in Japan on global standard 126 million
dollars you wouldn't even try to build a
another yet another mobile photo
photography app in Silicon Valley with
hundred point six million dollars but
they built a new materials company that
has it but has the I think really the
potential to replace an awful lot of
petroleum-based products in a whole
bunch of supply chains around the world
and they've done it in a tiny in a tiny
tiny town in the middle of nowhere in
western Japan but anyway so they're
they're my favorite startup because they
elected they prove me wrong they proved
though they haven't yet they're there
they're there
step by step proving me wrong that if
you don't have to move to Silicon Valley
to recruit world class time you don't
have to move to Silicon Valley to build
a well funded startup and
they may have been able to do it faster
they may they may still be able to grow
faster in the future were they to get
you know bigger than dollar financing
rounds like so that starts from
something like envision capital or or
others but but they are they are my my
favorite start to watch in Japan just
because everything they're accomplishing
it's like violates all of my assumptions
about what what's possible but would you
say they're really exceptional are you
do you think there's a lot of companies
that are starting to have that good I
think fibers exceptional I think I think
spike spire is unique in the world I
don't I don't think any any startup
anywhere in the world is will will today
or in the future accomplish as much
they've accomplished on with a little
funding and just as much vision and
passion and and and hard work because
they have so I think they are unique in
the world but I think there are a number
of startups in Japan like like the guys
from Muji like sorta comm there are
there are there are I think a larger
number of startups in Japan undertaking
serious materials hardware
IOT so one of the things I think is
interesting about Japan today is there's
a lot of hype around AI there are lots
of great AI researchers in Japanese
universities IOT is it's like the play
in the market where you want to apply it
the most as Japan and yeah kind of globe
a the global high claims there's a
global hype thing or Japan there's a
work and a lot of work in robotics right
now and and Japan is your ideal market
to engage is amazing so there's a lot of
there's a lot of emerging hot categories
in startup finance today where Japan has
some some as a market and as a talent
base of some organic natural potential
that that I'm hopeful we'll see some
global investors showing more interest
I'm hoping that at some point some song
will get his vision team to local
opportunities in Japan not just China
and Silicon Valley is that with a
hundred billion dollars to invest
were they to engage effectively with
with a handful of excellent entrepeneurs
in Japan the the funding and the you
know the local access to talent and some
topic could make a big difference if
they look inside the country not jet
outside okay so why don't we take a few
minutes and open the floor up to
questions from you you've been very
quiet listening to us talk go ahead
[Music]
not many entrepreneurs not many
companies so you don't have competition
so you can get a lot of you know cash
government and corporates and plus the I
think the startup cost is pretty minimal
because the payroll is over there's
there's no and even the Scott would have
a GD court you guys $40,000 yeah so it's
very cheap and also deer eaten
maintaining sometimes 74 and 80 percent
of ownership as a founder this is over
they were weak then you can get to I
don't having the trading companies
within maybe two or three years yeah you
can somebody turn that around into a
question that's right yeah because I
understand your point and you know
that's an interesting situation you can
flip that around and say is Silicon
Valley overpriced is Silicon Valley at
the end of its Road and what do you
think I thought I thought that Silicon
Valley was overpriced and full of waste
for a long time and yet you know if I've
thought that for since the internet
bubble and somehow Silicon Valley
continues to create enough just enough
exceptional startups and has such a
powerful brand that money continues to
flow here and get used to drive up real
estate prices and cost living for all of
us so I I like I don't
I've stopped forecasting the end of
Silicon Valley however
China passed Japan as the number to GDP
a few years ago it is within a year or
two of passing the United States in
venture capital investment and so if if
I were Chinese national studying at
Stanford or Berkeley and thinking of
starting a company I would go home and
start at home started at home probably
with a view to growing a business that
has global potential if if I were a
Japanese studying or active here in
Silicon Valley I would be tempted to
stay here to do it because because the
ecosystem for starting the companies in
Japan is not strong enough I agree that
there are all kinds of the the cost of
exceptional talent in Japan is
extraordinary and I'm surprised that
more Silicon Valley companies and more
Chinese companies aren't sourcing the
engineers aren't sorted engineering
talent in Japan
rather than India nowadays I think that
low wage is part of the profits part of
the reason because Japanese stars tend
to think of themselves as small
businesses and the VCS think of the
small businesses the CEO shouldn't pay
himself a lot
he shouldn't pay his employees a lot
your small biz you're not a big trading
company or small business pay the
salaries of small business and I think
part of the leadership bench problem
could be solved if Japanese founders are
willing to give up 30% of the of their
ownership to employee stock options and
willing to give up another 30% to VCS to
array to raise 30 million dollars to pay
a salary better than you can get a
Mitsubishi so if the salary to work at a
hot startup was better than the salary
you could get at meat so be she or
Sumitomo bank or working for MIDI you
would see even better talent moving to
start Sina so I think I think that the
the low salary of engineering talent is
actually part of the problem that feeds
into the the smaller outcomes
of startups in Japan the fact that there
are so many talented people are willing
to work for less and there's a mentality
of ventures being small businesses in
Japan but I think it limits you know the
potential growth of a lot of the
startups there but you're absolutely
right that the it is it is especially
for materials science or nanotech type
companies it'd be a great big great
place to start business thank you
Takayama son I saw next your first okay
Evan you comment the money going to the
startup system for example one theory of
Malik bam ba-ba-bam beyond us - I will
be used for the market of day else best
field including the stimulating startup
company there so what aspect can be
improved by investing by investing from
kilometres higher and also what what
aspect can be getting worse by investing
from government aside the +1 is never
good support well I think the the
government based investing and I have
the most direct visibility understand
and CJ
activities for the last several years so
the the first thing that happened is
when they had 10 billion dollars to
invest they couldn't imagine how to miss
didn't start up so they spent a lot of
money on big corporate projects and
spin-offs now it was the fritters in the
second generation they had only a small
number of people who had experience
investing in and helping the growth of
young startups so there's a lot of
former consultants a lot of former
government officials who can think
strategically who can do MBA italic type
analysis and those skills are very very
good for private equity type business
Reformation business enhancement so
taking established business improving it
is a skill set that the consultant back
the consultant people hired by at CJ
would be really good at so for a large
company private equity type
restructuring deal the talent that and
so the problem I see with the government
funds they tend to want to recruit
really smart consultants because I think
consultants understand business
understand growth and consultants
are sometimes the worst person you could
apply to engaging a start-up and helping
a start-up work through its issues
because it has to be much more you know
white sheet free thinking and it's much
more about how deep you have to bow to
get somebody to agree about your product
not how proudly you can go in and
logically argue it so I think I think
there's a miss a mismatch often between
the type of people the government is
comfortable hiring to run these funds
and the backgrounds they look for versus
the backgrounds and the kind of
mentoring that's good startup for you
but that said clearly the availability
of that capital to fund startups and the
mission assigned the mission to look at
startups that will be probably the the
best source of waste that drives the
ecosystem in Japan so because the
government would like to get its money
back but the government is not looking
to make a big profit on its investments
and so on similar they may be willing to
take more risks than a private VC would
in Japan and certainly with that that
amount of money
dedicated to space they will make a lot
of bets a lot of them will not work out
hopefully some of them do so I think
having that large amount of capital to
invest in it in a well-defined category
potentially creates enough volume of
investment for Silicon Valley style
waste or China style waste to kick in
and out of that out of the many wasted
deals emerge one or two really
exceptional deals is what I what I'm
sort of hope happens I think the same
thing is I could happen with the Tokyo
University 500 million dollar fund and
the the Kyoto and Kansai 209 of our
funds it's way too much money for a
single university to invest in
university related startups but if they
actively invest that of a reasonable out
of time there will be a handful of
exceptional companies that come out of
that and a lot of waste that hopefully
the exceptional companies make up for
the losses in total thanks I'll go ahead
no thank you typical mindset do people
in Japan really love doing the startup
on the other hand if
you start a company how easy is it to
recruit the talents because we know even
with this face prison is for start-up
here everyone is fighting for the talent
sector and the reverse situation in
Japan would that be the more common case
that people just don't want to consider
joining the startup the the people the
people the people who do start companies
are very dizzy asked about it so you
have you have to you have to be
passionate excited about the idea and
sometimes the idea is brilliant
sometimes it's crazy I don't think the
quality idea matters as much as how
passionately the person wants to pursue
it and so there their point there plenty
of entreprenuer enthusiastic and
passionate about starting companies but
certainly compared to Silicon Valley
there is not there is not a wave of
people waiting to jump from their last
exit to their new startup so the
phenomenon you see in Silicon Valley you
build a company sell it two years after
a year the month after your golden
handcuffs come come off jump to the next
startup for your next equity place so
the equity equity upside hopping that is
so common in Silicon Valley does not
exist in Japan largely because the the
typical stock option pool in Japan is
10% of the shares at the time of the IPO
there if they may have been set up and
wants and light so there's no
maintaining a pool 20% over time and
continuing to grant as your grew over
time so there's not a there's not a
continuous option pool and so you don't
see the job so that the people who tend
to join the startup companies are
friends of the founder or people younger
than the founder or friends of the
friends they hire so it tends to be in
the early stages much more limited to
people who know and trust and like the
founder and want to help him and those
people tend to be junior in age and/or
talent to the founders so you rarely see
a phenomenon which is common in the
valley that the founder is a tech geek
who knows about the product but he hires
some
far more capable than himself to run the
sales side of the business far more
cable than himself as CFO to run finance
and so over time the quality of the
leadership team in Silicon Valley tends
to have each member work even working
but when the founder at in the roles
that they perform whereas in Japan you
don't you don't see teams where the team
is more talented than they've done the
founder okay thank you yeah go ahead
wondering your thoughts on how the aging
population and negative population
growth influences the overall
startup ecosystem and just growth
businesses in Japan one way to the
dimples you see probably more startups
whose focus as a business is solving
some aspect of the aging population
problem so that I think there's a
there's a probably a larger percentage
of startups looking at and thinking
about how to society function as as it
ages you I'm not I'm not sure how
strongly related but but discussion in
the government about the problem of the
aging population and how this is going
to impact big companies and the
economy's ability to function as a whole
we're happening in parallel with with
the conversations about we need to get
more startups going to get more new
companies forming and growing and so I
think at some level at some level as a
policy issue as well a vibrant startup
ecosystem is seen as part of the
solution to the on the potential decline
of established companies as their
founders and founding teams move on and
there is a lot there's a lot there's one
other phenomena I don't know how common
is the United States there's a
phenomenon in Japan of children
inheriting their father's business
taking the cash flow around the original
business and turning that into a
completely new business sometimes
getting outside financing so there is a
there is a form of entrepreneurship
funded by the cash flow of the business
inherited from my father
that is not uncommon in Japan as well
thank you go ahead take the question
back to the issue of fun day won't you
say what you attribute to the disparity
between like the startup culture and the
funding scene between China and Japan
because I think I'm a very superficial
level they seem to have very similar
ideas about you know conformity and
community individualism
so I from the moment I started to notice
that the Indian startup scene and
Chinese startup scene look like they
were starting to take off about 2006 or
so some some of the Silicon Valley firms
were flying over to do investing there
were some local firms being formed I did
it then like I still do now to the world
geopolitics and world economy situation
of the 1980s and what was happening
1980s America was struggling with
recession and Japan was number one and
Americans of my generation were taking
Japanese in college and going to learn
how to how to operate American
businesses the way Japanese business
operated we there you know if you the
popular media of the time there's lots
of Hollywood movies in the 1980s where
Los Angeles streets are all in kanji and
they're Jeff famous Japanese brands all
over Times Square and so the world view
of the 1980s was Japan is number one
Japan's me to dominate America's and the
decline in Japan is on the emergent and
so if you're young if you're a young kid
just graduating from college in Japan in
the 1980s of course you want to work for
me to be G or Sony or Panasonic because
you're your country those companies are
going to dominate the world and America
thought the same thing the time so
American students of my generation
really smart kids were going to work for
Sony and Nintendo and Toyota and Honda
there was a wave of Merit young talented
American people wanting to work for
Japanese companies for whatever reasons
whether its language or you know
this residual hard feelings about World
War 2 a lot of the really talented
Chinese who were being permitted to
study abroad on visas in the 1980s and a
lot of the Indians a lot of the Chinese
grad students and ingress students came
to Silicon Valley or came to the United
States and ended up working in junior
staff positions in Silicon Valley
startups the 1980s or Microsoft or
Oracle or Apple or Sun Microsystems and
so there was this way this generational
wave of the best and brightest of
Japan's young people joining Japanese
companies were going to lead the world
and not getting exposed to Silicon
Valley culture as young people and
growing through the ranks and learning
how southern Valley companies we're
learning how to manage the Silicon
Valley company and a generation of
Indians and Chinese who are going
through that experience and so as the
1990s came to an end and America had
recovered and had the internet bubble
and Japan had kind of gone into flat
growth decline and Japan Japanese are
kind of rethinking well what is lifetime
employ is there such thing as lifetime
employment what's what's our what's our
future as young people like by that time
there were people there were lots of
Chinese Indians that had 10-15 years
experience in management in Silicon
Valley and who had retained connections
with family and friends back in their
home country and who saw that China was
now on an emergent economic path and the
India was not a virgin academic path and
so there was this this generation of
well-trained well-connected Silicon
Valley savvy young potential
entrepreneurs many of whom chose to move
back to China back to India and apply
what they had experienced in Silicon
Valley in Japan Japan did not have that
generation at the time when it most
might have most wanted to have it so I
had to Butte a lot of that difference to
just the ongoing impact the ongoing
effects of how how the world those key
economies of the world were interact
with each other in the 1980s that kind
of lost generation fears is a very
interesting point to close our formal
session on cause we're out of time we've
got some refreshments outside please
join me outside and talking more without
an informative
his ideas on this and and other things
that we talked about today Alan thank
you so much
[Applause]
you